I heard that your dad actually taught
you to stick up for yourself right yeah
my dad I mean considering he's a very
kind of old school traditional English
gentleman yeah one thing he had always
said was just like oh my
daddy a beautiful you know he was uh
Roger Moore's body double back in the
day are you serious yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean go he's a slick looking man he is
but he was always you don't look half
bad yourself there just saying yeah I'm
like yeah he um yeah he always had my
back even from when I was like 10 12
years old when when his kind of dinosaur
friends would be kind of inappropriate
and say inappropriate things and I would
shoot straight back at them my dad would
just be like well you feel pretty stupid
now don't you to his friends oh my God I
love it and I think that's where how
inappropriate of his friends vile Pig
vomits
very just calling them out I love it
yeah yeah and I've been like it all you
have to or they'll feel comfortable
doing that with everyone and not
everyone is as Brave or bold as that you
know what I'm saying not I think that
comes from having a dad that was just
like go on my girl yeah yeah all right
well wait you shared you shared recently
that you're currently in a give no era
yeah here's here's my thing absolutely
zero I have been in that
era I feel like you and I youor and I oh
yeah yeah we are fully as soon as you're
just fully bullied and you're like there
is no properly bullied yes me too yes
probably like One Time by a very tall
girl she shall name name I can't say it
name remain nameless I can't say it I
have been drinking now yeah no she like
pushed my head she just would literally
physically harm me at school and I was
little like I was like yes camera Le on
in your face who you are
yeah so yeah
exactly did you get that cuz you're I
imagine you didn't cuz you're tall you
could have like what you say I got it no
cuz I wasn't I wasn't I was quite
shy I I was too nobody believes me yeah
no I was I wasen to us we called
introverted extroverts that's what it is
it is actually yeah they used to tease
me about my height when they were all
you know much much smaller than me and
so likewise where's the camera in your
face look at me now yeah um okay wait
speaking okay I we speaking can I say
you look so
hot so you I love your new hair I love
your hair thank you thank you I
[Music]
[Applause]
mean thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home